so hey how's the tour going to moon 5
this is huge big deal yeah
tours going really good we started our
second leg like three weeks ago and we
still got another three weeks ago but
it's been awesome every so it's been
really fun how do you like are you ever
concerned because you I mean there's so
much of your voice that played you ever
concerned at some point that you like oh
I'm feeling it I'm gonna burnt out oh
yeah
the other day I was starting to feel it
a little bit but what I do usually is
just not talk like I'm just like guys
I'm gonna feeling I'm feeling a certain
way I need to just not talk be by myself
for a second cuz if I'm around people
I'm talking right like I need I need
space so I can just you need a
whiteboard you can write board around
with you it's like you write down what I
need this way so we all know Adam of
course from years and years of music and
the voice how is it working with them oh
it's fun we basically just talked to
each other every day I mean that's
pretty much our relationship it's all
rooted in love but we just we are just
sarcastic to each other at every chance
we can get it's it's awesome
that's hilarious and we've we've talked
to a Keith Urban and Shawn Mendes both
and they say that working with you and
writing with you is kind of like a
stream of consciousness
it just happens and it's spontaneous are
there ever any moments here in your
student consciousness something comes
out you like Oh put it back in no I
think a lot of the things that I say are
very intentional yeah and I think a good
part of the creative process is daring
the suck so you know if you say
something stupid or ridiculous it can
sometimes lead to something amazing or
something so you just never know is that
a quality that you've always had the
ability to say you know something I came
up with isn't great and move on or did
you have to learn that and get you said
it's something I think I've learned you
know if something doesn't feel right or
it just doesn't it's not moving as
quickly as you would like it to than a
lot of the times they'll be let's come
back to this let's see if we can do
something else and sometimes sometimes
going back to something you're like oh
actually this is really good so it's
listening to it with you know fresh airs
from a fan point of view people can have
sort of a misconception that the
finished product is was kind of perfect
from sometimes it is sometimes it's not
there have been songs that have been
written in you know an hour two hours
and sometimes you leave and you're like
this is weirdly great I don't know how
but it's great yeah and there are some
songs that you listen to and you're like
we should take this out and we should
add this and this guitar part should go
here instead of there yeah so sometimes
it's a bunch of frankensteining and
other times it's it's kind of perfect
for you instead
do you often have fans that come up to
you and profess you like you're doing
what I want to be doing yeah how do I do
it yeah yeah yeah the question I get the
most is you know how do I get to your
position basically so which I always say
just be you just be authentically you if
you you know have anxiety tell people
you know like you just never know who
you're helping or you know
another one I always say is just like
don't follow trends I feel like a lot of
the times people think that they have to
do something specific that's current now
because it makes them it'll make them
feel relevant yeah and I don't I just
don't think you have to do something
like that the world might be missing out
on great music and a lot of talent when
people don't believe that they can do it
or they're not encouraged to do it so
would you say to young women especially
who don't have that encouragement feel
like they can't do it or have someone
telling them that they're it's not gonna
happen for them
use it to your advantage for the road
yeah that's what I would say yeah I'm
something that's really exciting that we
think is phenomenal is that you'll work
with a star is born
LaRhonda star is born either co-wrote
lights the music they're awesome music
supervisor uh no no I just did I just
did one one one little song so how did
that happen is it something that you
know someone came to you and they said
we want you to do this or did you have
music already ready we had written that
song with Gaga a year ago or a year and
a half ago and we were writing it we're
writing it I don't remember why we just
had a session and it just happened and
and we didn't really think anything of
it we we thought it was just kind of
like gonna go away and then a couple
months later we heard it was gonna be in
the movie and were like holy cow that's
fantastic I think great yeah it's the
only session we ever did together so
it's pretty cool that's amazing it's
that that's sort of like preparedness
meets opportunity
right just yeah yeah we you know she's
just never know what could happen and
now it's something it's end of movie and
it's gonna be really cool
I'm really excited for it when you're
working with different people I mean
Gaga Keith Urban Sean Adam does your
approach change depending on the person
that you're working with or do they know
coming in like this is how Julia works
and we're just gonna make this happen no
it depends you know sometimes people
come in with ideas or they come in and
they talk about something and you know
that conversation can lead to something
special or you know that line that they
say could be amazing and you know work
off of that it really just depends on
who you're with in the situation and the
day
weather and all that stuff yeah and when
you're on tour like how do you keep it
up how do you keep your energy up for
your fans every stop well I don't do
this for me a lot of the times when I'm
performing I'm doing it for them I want
to make sure they have a good time and
they're happy and they feel something
you know so a lot of the times if I feel
sad if I feel a little under the weather
I just push it back for a little bit